Bezahlte trolle
Desinformation social bots und leaks immer wieder gerät russland in diesem zusammenhang in verdacht und experten sind sich einig der kampf um die
internationale macht und vorherrschaft wird von der russischen regierung ins netz verlagert manche vermuten eine ganze fake news
Maschinen travel und die große gefahr ist mehr als offensichtlich die öffentliche meinung wird manipuliert wahlen beeinflusst und die stimmung wird aufgeheizt
Mal sehen was hier unter dem video so passiert manche nennen es schon den krieg des 21 jahrhunderts
Was und wer genau dahinter steckt viele spannende beispiele dafür und wie gefährdet wir in deutschland wirklich sind jetzt in klicks um
Science-fiction herzlich willkommen übrigens, am ende des videos gibt es eine gratis seid gespannt
Im internet gelten andere regeln als in der echten welt das netz wird zunehmend zum spielfeld eine
auseinandersetzung die militärexperten
mittlerweile als krieg bezeichnen waffen und ziele bestehen hier aus informationen es gibt schätzungen nach denen dieser krieg mehr als
10.000 tote und millionen vertriebene zur folge hat ein krieg den der stellvertretende us-verteidigungsminister
bob burg in einer rede
2015 als labor für die kriegsführung des einundzwanzigsten
Jahrhunderts genannt hat einer der sich an dem krieg der von tastaturen ausgeführt wird beteiligt ist neo, man
Sah ein aktivist aus donetsk etwa
50 jahre alt der alle seine freizeit auf verschiedenen russischen zwischen medienseiten verbringt dies kennt der durch und hört
Zudem prorussische funkkanäle ab ich kann nicht als soldat kämpfen also versuche ich auf diese weise mein bestes zu tun sagt er
Auch, im fall einer 17 waren leute wie er in gewisser weise
Verstrickt eine stunde vor dem start der maschine am amsterdamer flughafen schreibt eine romanze auf twitter
es ähnelt stark an der bug also einem mobilen russischen boden luft raketen system mit mittlerer reichweite
Konkret kann sich um eine 34 tonnen schwere book m1 teller das steht für transporter auf richter
trägerrakete und radar das waffensystem wird begleitet von ihren lehrern truppen eine halbe stunde später die ma 17 ist längst gestartet und mittlerweile
Etwa 30 minuten in der luft jetzt meldet ein ukrainischer aktivist etwa. Wh er?
Habe den konvoi durch die stadt tores versehen etwa 45 meilen östlich von dollars und in richtung der stadt schnitt
Später wurde das system dann tatsächlich in einem feld aufgestellt um 24 ortszeit feuerte es dann eine
1.500 kontrakte ab ist fast dreifacher schallgeschwindigkeit
stieg sie auf
33.000 fuß höhe ausgestattet war sie mit einem
154 von schweren gefechtskopf der etwa vier meter schräg links oberhalb der flugzeugnase
explodiert sein muss ein fragment davon fanden die ermittler bei der autopsie der 15 crewmitglieder und der
283 passagiere im körper eines
besatzungsmitgliedes hunderte metall fragmente fanden sie auch in der leiche des kapitäns und 120
Im körper eines offiziers unter dem passagier, man
Im übrigen 80 kinder die absturzstelle der immer 17 hat da ein osze
Ermittler als den größten tatort der welt
bezeichnet wirklich mehr als grausam und noch bis heute ist unklar wer genau den knopf freigegeben hat die russische regierung
Hat sich in diesem. Fall immer weiter verstrickt die taktik scheint
zu sein kritiker unglaubwürdig zu machen und von sich selbst abzulenken
hoch automatisierte netzwerke von bots sorgen genauso wie bezahlte tolle dafür dass anschuldigung und
Ablenkungsmanöver massenhaft verbreitet werden eine breite front die sich da aufgestellt hat ihre gegner
freiwillige die sozialen netzwerke als
ermittlungs grundlage nehmen wie zum beispiel das crowdfunding
projekt berlin kat das drei tage vor dem mhh 17 absturz gestartet war nicht einmal sechs stunden nachdem emma 17
abgeschossen wurde hatte sein gründer ein
Spannendes video gefunden es zeigt wie die buck durchs nischen erfährt
genau dieses video findet zwei jahre später seinen platz in dem abschlussbericht des internationalen
untersuchungsteams das berlin kennt netzwerk hat nur ein minimales budget und trotzdem haben seine teilnehmer
unglaubliches geleistet auf social media beiträgen und frei verfügbaren satelliten fotos haben sie ihre ergebnisse gewonnen unter anderem die
identifikation der burg einheit nummer 333 und das zugehörige bataillon der 53
flugabwehrraketen brigade in russland dazu verglichen sie unzählige fotos und fokussierten sich dabei auf charakteristische
Merkmale wie beulen und die anordnung von
kabelverbindung zum raketen auf richter die belling cat aktivisten waren auch diejenigen die als erstes
öffentlich den weg beschrieben haben denen die burg zurückgelegt hatte ein ungleich höheres budget zur
aufklärung des ema 17 abschlusses hatte natürlich das offizielle niederländische ermittlungsteam der
sicherheitsausschuss zur verfügung gleich hunderte ermittler vernahmen mehr als 200 zeugen und
1400 watt stücke wurden untersucht und eine halbe million fotos und videos wurden analysiert der kostenpunkt dafür
4,8 millionen us dollar die vorläufigen ergebnisse des sicherheitsausschusses gab es
Im september letzten jahres demnach war eine. Puk m1 teller von der russischen föderation
Die ukraine gebracht worden und feierte dort die entscheidende rakete ab danach wurde das waffensystem nach
Russland zurückgebracht die russische antwort auf diese enthüllung war allerdings eher eine fast zunächst beschuldigte die regierung einen ukrainischen
Kampfjet dann waren ukrainische bodentruppen und später auch die ci
verantwortlich später gab es dann noch die behauptung dass eigentlich putins
privatflugzeug das ziel gewesen sei dass alles lief durch eine art nebelmaschine troll farm
halbautomatische botnetze und die russischen staatsmedien haben in diesem kontext ganze arbeit geleistet
Gleichzeitig wurde auch auf die gegner geschossen es gab
hacker-angriffe auf den niederländischen
sicherheitsausschuss und spear phishing
Angriffe auf das berlin cats netzwerk und das war tatsächlich nur der auftakt für ein weitaus größeres spiel es folgten
hacker-angriffe auf die nato
französische medien auf verschiedene regierungen und die osze auch der deutsche bundestag war betroffen immer wieder tauchte dabei
einnahme einer bestimmten hackergruppe auf fancy bier auch strontium
Und white oder zart ihm genannt
Sicherheitsexperten und experten bezeichnen die gruppe als ep
28 laura galante arbeitet für ein it sicherheitsunternehmen und für sie ist die lage klar denn schon
im jahr 2007 hätten kollegen und kolleginnen die malware identifiziert die sich hauptsächlich gegen politische oder militärische
ziele richten zitat diese software wurde offenbar über einen längeren zeitraum entwickelt sie wurde nicht für den einmaligen gebrauch
geschrieben das wertet sie als hinweis darauf dass eine organisation dahinter stecken muss ein festes team das immer mit denselben werkzeugen zuschlägt und
langfristig plant möglicherweise
auch ein staatlicher akteur die daten verraten zudem dass sie in der zeitzone von
moskau kontrolliert worden waren nach galante spricht alles dafür dass fans sie bier hinter all diesen
angriffen steckt expertinnen und experten vermuten dass diese hacker gruppe, zudem enge verbindungen zu
dem russischen militär geheimdienst hat ein fbi
chef bezeichnete sie mehr als sehr laut denn wenn sie bier macht sich offensichtlich keine große mühe seine
aktivitäten zu verschleiern und genau deswegen
zweifeln manche experten
Experten halten es für möglich dass dabei wir völlig anderes unter falscher flagge agiert doch was will russland damit bezwecken was ist das
langfristige ziel der kreml regierung galante ist sicher dass putin nicht nur zitat die physische
westliche dominanz sondern auch die fähigkeit des westens globale werte und normen zu definieren
infrage stellen will zitat ende
Demnach sollen alle möglichst bald an der liberalen westlichen welt ordnung zweifeln und galante ist nicht die einzige die das
Befürchtet nicht umsonst hat die eu im jahr 2015 die taskforce
strategische informationen ost ins leben gerufen mehr als 500 zuarbeiter der elf
kommunikationsexperten haben keine geringere aufgabe als russische falschmeldung zu entlarven eine ganze fake news maschine
Im kreml also die urheberschaft der russischen regierung lässt sich zwar nie eindeutig nachweisen
Doch die indizien sind erdrückend laut experten nur experten tragen die kampagnen die handschrift
russischer geheimdienste die jahrzehntelange erfahrung mit versteckten operationen sammeln konnten in vielen staaten von osteuropa dem baltikum
skandinavien bis nach mitteleuropa gebe es gezielte desinformations kampagnen da sind sich experten und expertinnen sicher die
Kernbotschaft sei immer gleich traue niemandem und wenn man die ganze
Feld novelle sieht ist sogar us präsident donald trump dieser kampagne aufgesessen herzlichen glückwunsch
besser hätte es nicht laufen können der in russland geborene sicherheits analytiker
anderson sagt klipp und klar zitat
Das erste was man verstehen muss ist dass das ein krieg ist das ist kein witz und das ist kein spiel es geht nicht um
geselligkeit mit freunden den sozialen netzwerken sogar die die nicht teilnehmen wollen müssen sich nach
Den gesetzen des krieges verhalten zitat ende seiner meinung nach verwendet die putin regierung methoden des kalten krieges
Um die liberale demokratie der westlichen welt zu sprechen
Europäische wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler sind mit dem begriff krieg etwas vorsichtiger der politologe simon hegele ich aus münchen spricht von
manipulation
strategien die angewandten strategien stamm seiner ansicht nach zwar aus dem militärischen und dem geheimdienst bereich seien aber aktuell
Frei auf dem markt verfügbar vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an die verschwörungstheorien während des amerikanischen
wahlkampfes stichwort pizza gate die cia habe julian assange ermordet oder hillary clinton aber packen sind oder
Was da alles wird verbreitet worden war das alles verunsichert die leute und könnte laut ekelig dazu führen dass sie am ende
zitat nur noch einfache antworten von populistischen parteien glauben
Und wenn ein verwirrter sänger wie xavier naidoo dann auch noch darauf reinfällt das ist doch alles perfekt
Die große und alles entscheidende frage, am ende sind wir dem ganzen einfach
So ausgeliefert das hängt wohl von der aktuellen lage eines landes ab und der stimmung der menschen täglich zufolge sind die usa wohl
anfälliger da das land seit jahren gespalten und durch die finanzkrise zusätzlich verunsichert sei
desinformation social bots und leaks haben in deutschland dagegen wohl nicht
So einen großen einfluss das hat lisa maria neu das vom oxford
internet institute zur festgestellt 4 bis 15 prozent der tweets die hier zur landtagswahl
Im saarland und zur bundespräsidentenwahl verbreitet worden waren stammen ihrer analyse wohl von
automatisierten accounts in russland seien bei
politischen themen mit rund 40 prozent zu rechnen auch der fettanteil sein deutschland geringer ihr rad eine gesunde skepsis
Denn nicht alles was in sozialen netzen wichtig ist entspricht auch den realen
interessen der menschen ja ein absolutes
Thema da wird sicher noch eine menge darüber zu erfahren geben aber ich habe jetzt das
versprochene bulli für euch in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von technology review ist dieses video entstanden und
Exklusiv für pixum zuschauer gibt es ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link klickt es lohnt sich kann ich
nur sagen
technology review ist wirklich eine ganz fantastische
Zeitschrift immer super recherchiert wie auch dieses thema und hier geht es zu einem weiteren video das wir mit der redaktion gemacht haben virtual reality
Verändert die welt blickt drauf wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann